Game of Thrones has been all about big revelations
lately.
Beyond the explicit discoveries made by fans
and characters in the show's last few episodes,
however, the show may also have inadvertently
revealed something else about its primary
villain.
One fan theory currently taking the internet
by storm claims that Thrones may have already
spoiled the identity of the Night King.
Though this theory has circulated through
the web since season seven concluded, it found
new traction following HBO's Inside the Episode
featurette for the season 8 premiere.
During the post-episode promo, Thrones co-showrunner
and director David Benioff offered up information
that many are taking as evidence that the
Night King is, in fact, a secret Targaryen.
"No one has ever ridden a dragon [...] except
for Dany.
Only Targaryens can ride dragons, and that
should be a sign for Jon.
Jon's not always the quickest on the uptick
but eventually gets there."
As the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
Stark, Jon's Targaryen blood makes him worthy
to ride a dragon, though he doesn't know it
at the time.
And while Benioff might be right in saying
that only Targaryens can ride dragons, he's
wrong to say that Dany was the only person
to have ridden a dragon before the first episode
of season 8.
Remember this?
(why you shouldn't you mix Pop Rocks and Slurpees)
That makes three people who have ridden dragons
during the series so far: Daenerys on Drogon,
Jon on Rhaegal, and the Night King on Viserion.
Naturally, this has a huge subsection of the
Game of Thrones fandom thinking the Night
King could be a Targaryen.
After all, if dragon riders are Targaryens
and the Night King is a dragon rider, then
surely the Night King must be a Targaryen,
too?
Unfortunately, it's not hard to pick holes
in this theory.
For starters, Viserion isn't the same type
of dragon he was before he died.
He's an Ice Dragon now, not a Fire Dragon,
and it stands to reason that the old rules
don't exactly apply in this situation.
And while the Targaryens do have a deep connection
with dragons, they don't appear to have any
historic link to Ice Dragons.
According to Game of Thrones author George
R.R. Martin's novella The Ice Dragon, humans
can't tame, train, or ride Ice Dragons.
A portion of the text reads:
"We have tales of those that tried, found
frozen with their whip and harness in hand.
I've heard about people that have lost hands
or fingers just by touching one of them.
Frostbite."
Another problem with the theory that the Night
King is a Targaryen is that the Night King
is a member of the First Men, who came to
Westeros from Essos 12,000 years prior to
the Targaryen Conquest.
After the First Men invaded Westeros, the
ancient Westerosi inhabitants known as the
Children of the Forest captured one of them
- and the Night King was born.
Neither House Targaryen nor the Valyrian Empire
from which they came were around during this
time, and the Targaryens didn't rise to power
in the Valyrian Freehold until thousands of
years after the war between the First Men
and the Children of the Forest.
Taking this timeline into account, it seems
impossible that the First Man who became the
Night King could have been a Targaryen.
On the other hand, there's no getting around
one strange similarity between the Night King
and House Targaryen that people picked up
on during the season 8 premiere.
In one of the final scenes of the episode,
Eddison Tollet, Beric Dondarrion, and others
reach Last Hearth and find little Lord Umber
pinned to a wall with several severed limbs
surrounding his body, mapped out in the shape
of a spiral.
We've seen that spiral a few times before:
once around the Weirwood tree when the Children
of the Forest created the Night King, again
when the White Walkers slaughtered horses
to terrorize the wildlings, and finally in
etchings carved in the caves of Dragonstone.
But it might not be a coincidence that this
spiral also looks a whole lot like the sigil
of House Targaryen - and spirals of a kind
have even been known to appear around the
story's two living Targaryens.
Could this mean that the Night King is related
to the Targaryen family in some way?
Considering his ability to ride Viserion,
there really may be some relation.
Then again, maybe there isn't.
"Close the bloody gate."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.